se a efe una función tal que efe de
menos uno es igual a tres y f prima de
menos uno es igual a cinco se hace la
función de x igual a 1 sobre x sea f
mayúscula la función definida por f
mayúscula de x es el producto de las
funciones de p&g entonces cuál es la
derivada de f mayúscula de menos 1 para
resolver esto simplemente aplicamos la
regla del producto y que nos dice la
regla del producto bueno como f
mayúscula de x es el producto de estas
dos funciones si aplicamos la regla del
producto entonces tenemos que la
derivada de f mayúscula de x será igual
a efe prima de x que multiplica ag de x
+ fx que multiplica g prima de x ahora
nosotros queremos evaluar a la derivada
de f mayúscula en menos 1 entonces
tenemos que f mayúscula prima de menos 1
es igual a la derivada de f evaluada en
menos 1
multiplica a g el valor del menos uno
más
efe del -1 multiplicado por la derivada
de g el valor del -1 entonces vamos a
resolver esto muy bien entonces
conocemos la primera derivada de efe - 1
si aquí nos dice que f prima de menos 1
es igual a 5 por lo tanto esto es igual
a 5
efe - 1 eso es igual a 3 aquí nos dice
entonces efe - 1 es igual a 3 ahora
ag de menos 1 viaje prima de menos 1 no
los conocemos no no sabemos esto
explícitamente pero podemos averiguar lo
sabemos kg de x es igual a 1 sobre x
entonces
evaluando el -1 tenemos que g de menos
uno es igual a 1 sobre menos uno que es
igual a menos uno por lo tanto g de
menos uno es igual a menos uno y por
último que prima de menos uno bueno
vamos a averiguar que es que prima de
menos uno lo que necesitamos hacer es
tomar la derivada de esto entonces vamos
a tomar la derivada de esto gdx es igual
a 1 sobre x ajá pero uno sobre x es lo
mismo que x a la menos 1 ahora vamos a
usar la regla de la potencia y entonces
tenemos que que prima de x es igual aquí
bajamos el exponente y lo ponemos en
frente tenemos menos 1 que multiplica a
x elevado a la menos dos así que g prima
de menos 1 es igual a menos 1 que
multiplica a menos 1 elevado a la menos
lo mismo es lo mismo que menos 1 sobre
menos 1 al cuadrado ahora menos 1 al
cuadrado eso es igual a 1 por lo tanto
esto será igual menos 1 sobre 1 es igual
a menos 1
por lo tanto tenemos que g prima de
menos 1 es igual a menos 1 y entonces
tenemos 5 x menos 1 eso es menos 5 + 3 x
menos 1 eso es menos 3 ahora menos 5
menos tres es igual a menos 8 por lo
tanto la derivada de f mayúscula
evaluada en menos uno es igual a menos 8